then I feel something tickle my haters
it felt like a feather I turn around
there's no one there it's now I think
something paranormal is happening like
it's Liberace's ghosts going hi
[Music]
[Applause]
Tiger rally please give it up for
hilarious company mr. Bobby Lee it
involves sexualities and it's unholy and
15 years ago I totally you guys know
that I just couldn't get laid
I'm shaped like a human dumpling I look
like Pikachu with diabetes I don't look
good I don't even know how to this
is what I do like a hula hoop 15
years ago
I got a gig in Las Vegas my first
headlining gig at the Riviera and they
were gonna pay me $150 thank you one
show and I'm making it and he wouldn't
fly me out so I had these two comics
drive me to Las Vegas Brian
he's a real guy and airing and we drive
to Las Vegas and we're on Las Vegas
Boulevard we're at a stoplight and we're
in Brian's uh Bronco and a truck pulls
up next to us a blue truck with two of
the ugliest white girls I've ever seen
in my life they were twins
they had mullets yet Confederate flag
t-shirts on dad wash jeans I'm getting
hard right now
and they yell into the car we think
you're cute
they weren't talking about me they
weren't talking about Brian because
Brian is the ugliest white do whatever
rossini if you know Brian
he has no jawline or chin his
neck just blends into his face he looks
like a tiki statue or Beeker from the
Muppets he looks awful he has a Gollum
body you know white guys have skinny
arms in a belly
god damn he's unfuckable anyway guys the
reason why I just said that I called him
up because I asked him to do the story
with me he said no I have kids
you Brian you were talking about
Aaron and Aaron jumps out of the Bronco
he goes into the truck and they just
drive into the distance you know I mean
we're like hope you don't die so we go
to the Riviera and it's like Nadia and I
tell Brian I go Brian I need to write on
a setlist so uh just do your own thing
I'll see you at the show it's at
midnight so I go do my set list at
midnight I show up at the Riviera and
Aaron and Brian rolls up with these two
girls and Aaron pulls me aside and says
hey dude if you're funny they'll
you then Aaron goes yeah because they're
white supremacist I sorta God
so then yes I'll do it then because if
your ethnic you to white
supremacist that's a win for my people
they're gonna build a statue of me in
Seoul so I go up and I do the show and
I'm pretty good you know I mean I'm
likeable focus groups like me
I test well and after the show we go up
to the room and it's debauchery I mean
the air is thick it's like a Cambodian
jungle you can slice the air with the
machete you're mean and we were all
wearing condoms so it's two hours of
just sexualities and
I get the skinny one we switch off
eventually I have the fat one on the
band right one of them was fat by the
way I'm doing doggy style and Aaron has
the other one in the other bed and I
look wrong with a fox Brian
nobody knows where Brian is he
disappeared the bathroom light is off
right so he's not in there so I could
him I keep going right then I feel
something tickle my anus it felt like a
feather I turn around there's no one
there so now I think something
paranormal is happening like it's
Liberace's ghosts going high or whatever
so I keep going right I definitely feel
something rubbing against my anus right
Brian had crawled underneath my body
underneath her body and started eating
around while I was walking her which
makes him a warrior he's a
soldier guys I gave him a Purple Heart
afterward seriously I go get the
out of there you guys she likes it she
likes it all right I keep going I start
calling her you know you do it
you power
you speak English that I don't know
power like a rabbit and my penis
flips out and it goes right into Brian's
eye
I've never heard a scream that loud
before crazy and then we stopped
immediately putting a penis in an eye is
a party stopper I don't care where you
are right it just ruins the mood you can
get a gold medal at the Olympics as they
bring the ribbon around your
neck and Opie goes in your eye it's done
okay so anyway we get up and I take him
to breakfast I do because I'm a good
person
so we're at breakfast and um we're
eating bacon or whatever and I looked
across and Bryce is completely closed
with a yellow film around it I know and
I go dude you're I because I think we
should go to the hospital of burns I got
some Clorox on it or whatever I want him
to lose the eye just for the story I
blinded a man with my penis once
so we've get in the car it's 6:00 in the
morning tired speak English
alright alright
we drive soon Hospital and I don't know
what to say I've never told the doctor
that I poked somebody in the eye with my
penis before you lie what the do
you do so Brian goes I got it so we're
sitting there in the emergency room
doctor walks and he says what happened
Brian points at me he says he skull-fuck
me that was a story
[Applause]